foreign
[Music]
first how you can build accessible
lessons with the carpentry's workbench
and second how we used R to build The
Carpenter's workbench which allowed us
to transform our lessons
from looking like this
to looking something a bit more like
this
and I have a lot of people that I need
to thank for this talk including the art
studio diversity Scholars Program which
brought myself and Dr soon to be Dr
Sharon hurt to this conference but I
don't really have the time to go over
this and
what you need to know about this talk is
that you need to know who the
carpentries are in order to appreciate
it in order to understand who the
Carpenters are I'm going to tell you a
little bit a little story about myself
this is not a recent photo this was from
2014. I was teaching my very first
conference Workshop in population
genetics and R giving it to plant
Pathologists if you're wondering about
population genetics in R is I think
23andMe but for fungi so in this
Workshop I wrote the I wrote the
materials
all in our markdown
um I forced my I force my advisor to use
git and uh ended up fixing a lot of
merge conflicts and the process of uh
building this was very painful it was
very much close your eyes and hope it
works
um I did end up building the website but
that version of me knew quite a lot
about
um
population genetics knew quite a lot
about Plant Pathology
didn't know very much about inclusive
teaching lesson design or live coding
and this Workshop it was actually
successful we ran it for two years got
really good reviews
uh people liked it but something was
really bothering me something was eating
me it's on the inside
I didn't actually know what people
learned
I knew they learned something they had
their computers open they were following
along
but I don't know what they learned and
here's the thing my advisor had no way
of supporting me in that he was a
government scientist
you know like he hadn't taught a course
in years
and so if I had a way to get the support
I needed such as maybe a template that
could have that could have given me the
narrative elements and um
and elements for formative assessment
I would have been able to succeed in
understanding what my Learners learned
and then improve the that lesson over
time
and I know now that the carpentries
provide that support and gives a safe
space for improving my teaching
and the carpentry is all about spreading
data science skills to research or
researchers around the globe to really
democratize access to data
and it does this by fostering
communities of practice
and these are volunteers who are trained
in evidence-based teaching principles
from all around the world and we all
come together through
shared core values
in that we we are motivated in that we
are always learning and we're inclusive
of all
in practice we act openly we Empower one
another and we value all contributions
which allows us to achieve our goals of
championing people first access for all
Community collaboration
and strength through diversity
and we know that it works because we
have led over 3 500 workshops in the
past 10 years
to over 60 countries 3 900 instructors
45 lessons to over 80 000 novice
Learners and over 90 member institutions
I know it's a lot of number
but the key to this
the reason why this works is because our
instructors never teach alone
in a carpentry's workshop
if you are an instructor you're if
you're new instructor you're always
paired with someone who's taught this
before
and this is always possible because of
uh of the efforts of our director of
workshops sure and hurt who allows you
who gives you the opportunity to teach
these workshops and these workshops
would not be possible without our open
source and open licensed materials that
are available on GitHub and it's these
materials that I'm going to talk about
for the rest of the talk because these
have a long history they were originally
written in HTML just straight HTML
um really difficult to write if you're
if you're not if you're really tired or
yeah eventually they switched over to
Jekyll which is github's default site
generator and I'm going to ask for a
little audience participation here okay
so I'm going to ask you three questions
if the answer is yes I want you to
clap twice okay with me so first
question just to get a Baseline
if you have ever used Jekyll clap twice
okay good if you have ever ever uttered
a curse word while using Jekyll clap
twice
that was about the same okay
if you have ever wanted to set your
laptop on fire while using Jekyll please
clap twice
okay so yeah jackal's kind of hard to
use
um and the thing is
it's
been shown as a barrier
when you're just trying to build the
lesson when you're trying to work on a
lesson
you just want to fix a typo you want an
updated image
and you you find this
really want to burn it all down uh it's
not easy to use and the thing is it's it
wasn't living up to our values this
really did not put people first this was
putting the machines first
and so I was hired in 2020 to reimagine
this infrastructure because it was clear
it was not living up to our values
and what I realized is that we really
need to separate the tools from the
content any anything everybody should
worry about is just writing being able
to write markdown or arm markdown and
get a website out of it and not having
to sift through all the output that's
that's contained in the same folder or
having to worry about tools breaking
and so this is this is how I created the
carpentry's workbench and this is a
series of packages that avoids having a
lesson being wrapped around a Blog
infrastructure and it keeps the tools
and outputs separate and it's based on
the philosophy of package Zone work
where you are
and
this uh it consists of three packages
the first package that you're going to
interact with is sandpaper this is what
orchestrates everything the only command
you really need to know is sandpaper
serve
the next package is on the inside and
you don't you don't you don't interact
with it so often but you do with it you
do uh sandpaper uses it in the back end
to help you validate your markdown to
make sure that it actually it actually
is going to do what you want it to do
and then coming in at the end is varnish
that allows you that gives you the
styling of your lessons to make sure
that your lessons are accessible and
beautiful
um and all of this was designed what I
like to call with what I like to call
core values driven design
and so I'm going to talk about about a
few of our core values and how the
design elements fit in with them
there are a lot more but I don't have
that much time
so the first thing I'm going to I'm
going to start with is championing
people first because really individuals
who make up our community
are the most important part of our
organization
and they are our strongest resource so
it only makes sense
that when I was looking for a static
site generator something to generate our
websites with
that I would choose something that had
the most on-ramps and really
R is the best resource
it makes the most sense
uh you saw it in ileana's talk and you
see it here and this tweet from Janita
Bellini
and she says that some people laugh when
I tell them that R's best feature is its
commit as a language is its Community
but I'm very serious especially Our
Ladies has been such a positive Agent of
Change for so many people
and that's that's one of the reasons why
y'all are here
like we are a good Community here we
know how to make people feel included
and so it only makes sense
another way that we're we're championing
people first is that we virtually
increase the number of instructors in
the room when you're teaching a lesson
and I'm going to explain what I mean by
that so you have your lesson it has code
examples and you want to teach someone
how to add a column to a data frame okay
so you you are working in our studio and
you show you show them the Code you run
the code and then you have output that
looks like this
you can't really tell what happened
because there are so many columns in the
data frame everything ran off the edge
if you were if
if you had the wisdom of the instructors
who came before you and yes you are
teaching with another instructor they
may know this but they may not
you would know
that you have to you have to add a
select command and so what we do
is we allow instructors to communicate
through time and space
by including by allowing them to include
instructor notes directly into the
lessons in in the context that that it's
needed
so that when you teach this lesson you
can change your behavior and you can
show the Learners what exactly they need
to know and reduce their cognitive load
and another way we we Champion people
first is that we include automation
oftentimes
as you're building our markdown packages
will update things fail you get a lot of
Errors you get warnings that don't make
sense because the package authors change
their change their packages
we avoid this by uh embedding REM RM
sorry in the in the uh on the back end
of sandpaper and the beauty about this
you don't need to know anything about
RMF in order to use this we lock the
packages we give you a way to update
them and we give you a way to pin them
uh so that your lessons are always
working and you have a way to
investigate what happens when packages
update and I'm going to show you that
some of that a little bit later
and really this leads me into the fact
that we Champion access for all
because it shouldn't matter what
packages you have on your system it
shouldn't matter what packages you have
in your Global Library you should be
able to build the lesson the same anyone
else can build the lesson
and so
I'm going I'm going to show you like uh
what happens when you don't have your
own computer when you're not on your own
computer and you receive a pull request
that changes a plot
but can anybody tell me what's going to
happen when this happens
probably not because it's just it's our
code
but seeing the output of the plot is
night and day
and we and we have embedded pull request
previews
for the intermediate markdown
um
for these lessons so that you can
confirm that things actually work
whether or not you have the tools
installed
and this is
and furthermore if you're writing an R
lesson sometimes you may forget to add
to include alternative texts or you have
you have link descriptions that don't
actually describe anything
and you say whoops
and it's it's this kind of this kind of
um
pre-flight validation that's done by
pegboard
that allows you to to take a step back
and say yeah I made a mistake and fix it
and that's really the key to that's
really the key to how we're championing
access for all and we're always learning
because
we're humans
we forget things
you shouldn't be punished you shouldn't
have like glaring errors
when you when you miss something when
you mistype something
and it shows that we're always learning
and I'm going to turn turn it on myself
I'm obviously
sandpaper is not the fastest thing in
the world the workbench is not the
fastest thing in the world
um but
I really want to address the uh Pink
Pachyderm in the premises
we don't use quarto yet
sorry
um but the way I design the way I
designed the system we're going to
include quarto in the future we just
need to get it stable in our system and
I built it to be flexible so it works on
the exact same principle that Corto
works
um
and then finally I want to get to the
fact that we Empower one another
the workbench is going to support 168
lessons uh come January
and this is really key because most of
these lessons are in the carpentry's
incubator in which people are actively
uh developing lessons working on lessons
testing them out teaching them and
getting feedback and revamping them in
this iterative development cycle that
eventually leads to peer review of
lessons
and the car this is
and the carpentry's workbench makes this
model sustainable it makes it much
easier for people to do these iterations
with all of these safeguards that we've
built into it
and so
it's here that
I want to I want to show you that it's
not I'm not the only one who thinks this
I'm not the only one who claims this
from UCL she's part of the learn
discover project
she forked sandpaper and made it run
python
okay she and she says that it was very
trivial and efficient to write custom
lessons with the carpentry's workbench I
have a link there my slides are online
I'll give you a QR code for that
uh Toby Hodges he's the curriculum lead
of the carpentries he works with the
community and he says the carpentry's
workbench has made it easier for people
to write maintain and teach lessons in
many different ways sometimes quite
profoundly
Sarah Stevens very embedded in the
carpentries and she says I'm really
excited to be able to use the
workbench's accessibility features
because she's tired of not of not having
reminders to add alt text
and finally Francois Michelle no so has
been working with the car with the
workbench since the beginning and he
says you only have to focus on writing
content and the workbench takes care of
the rest
and so here's the here's a link that you
can use and you can create your own your
own lesson using the workbench
and now you can build your own
accessible lesson using r
but that's not what the talk title is
y'all
okay what about friends huh
this is building accessible lessons with
r and friends and this is where I I put
in a plug for the carpentries
I want you all to get involved because
really we are a great Community there
are plenty of ways to become to be
involved in in the carpentries and it's
really a community of practice you get
you get so many opportunities to to
interact with people who really care
about teaching you can become an
instructor next summer we're going to
open up uh applications for maintenance
of our lessons you can teach create
contribute to or review a lesson or even
just take our materials and they're
they're completely open
or if you're part of an organization you
can have that organization enroll as a
member and use that to build your own
community in your in your organization
and that's and if you want to know more
we have a conference that's happening
right after this conference it's online
and we have an accessibility fund if you
want if you want to donate to it to make
sure that
um we have we have money for translators
money for people who do captioning and
it's free to attend so if you want to
learn more please attend uh I have my
slides I have information about the
workbench and I'd be happy to take any
questions if I have time
okay
thank you
[Music]